now as we close out the new year
the current year i should say and enter
the new year eight news now and our next
our sister stations are teaming up to
raise money to provide meals for one
million people in need with our super
bowl of caring
help out this year with the super bowl
of caring it began 30 years ago in a
church in south carolina with one prayer
on super bowl sunday to be mindful of
those who don't have a bowl full of soup
to eat the youth at that church took
that on as a as a challenge
and they asked the question what if
everybody watching the big game just
gave a dollar or one can of food and if
you look at that today that would be a
hundred million dollars in one day
executive director allison reese says
they've got a large network and by using
the tackle hunger map you can use the
search bar to find charities in your
neighborhood zip code or city to
encourage thinking locally about giving
to churches homeless shelters pantries
and food banks most people don't know
where their nearest food charity is
and that's something that we're trying
to address using our map super bowl of
caring doesn't deliver food directly it
acts more like a catalyst by infusing
money into the food charities across the
nation and with next our nation's
outreach this year the non-profit hopes
you will help raise more than one
million meals
[Music]
and you can help out our food bank right
here in las vegas which of course is
three square just click on the qr code
on the screen and make a donation you
can also find other charities in the
valley on the tackle hunger map as we
mentioned and it will count toward the
super bowl of caring goal